three years ago luxury travel agent
Roman chipparuga couldn't sell his
clients on a big opportunity a chance to
visit the International Space Station I
literally talked to everyone for two
years straight telling them about space
and initially the response was no thank
you I'm not interested but two years
later he sold a ticket for 50
.
it's a great looking photograph that
trip to the ISS is just one example of a
trend that some high-end travel agents
are seeing their wealthy clients want a
dose of adrenaline with their luxury
here's what's behind the trend and why
some experts are concerned about the
risks
tourists have been visiting Antarctica
since the 1950s
but in the last few years companies have
built infrastructure to make these trips
more appealing to the ultra rich like
these so-called Sky pods and those
experiences that they want to have
that prior to the pandemic might not
have even been on the radar are now sort
of front and center and on the bucket
list the the concept of YOLO you only
live once I think has really sort of
settled into the mindset of
post-pandemic Travelers tour operator
white desert has built three camps on
the continent the newest can only be
reached by private jet clients can repel
down Cliffs explore ice caves and Hike
among fledgling emperor penguins so the
bucket list trip has become a trip to do
immediately and those folks that have
done all of these things are looking for
more intrepid and truly unique and
enriching experiences
for these Travelers the cost can be over
a hundred thousand dollars for seven
days both the polar and Antarctic
regions are I would say that they are
booming and it's not just the regions
themselves it's the near Arctic in in
near Antarctic but the polar regions are
under threat from climate change the
world's ice is melting faster than ever
we're finding parts of the ice sheet are
melting now and possibly going into
irreversible melting and in 2022 a paper
found that each Antarctic tourist
corresponds to about 83 tons of snow
loss
some travel agents say that despite
risks clients are looking for the next
adventure and more Travelers are willing
to spend to reach these extreme
destinations without the hassle
the CEO of Adventure travel company
Untamed borders said one client wanted
to climb K2 but didn't have the two
weeks it takes to hike to base camp
since private aircraft aren't permitted
so close to the disputed border of
Pakistan and India Untamed borders
rented high altitude helicopters from
the Pakistani army what would have been
a 14-day Trek took just four hours in
the air and cost forty thousand dollars
as clients take on more risk some are
seeking extra support from companies
that specialize in stepping in when
things go wrong
Dan Richards crisis response company
Global rescue is expecting more than a
hundred thousand calls in 2023 with 2
000 missions and rescues the company saw
221 growth from 2019 to 2022 Richards
warned that Travelers should take risks
seriously I think that some of our you
know traveling members have a very firm
grasp on what the risks might be but
then there are others that get swept up
in the excitement of it and don't
necessarily consider whether or not
they're sort of a good fit for what it
might be that they're encountering and
on some of the most extreme trips
tourists are Beyond rescue if you're you
know 10 000 feet under the ocean or
you're you know five miles up in the
atmosphere
nobody's we're not only not going to be
able to get you nobody's going to be
able to get to you Richards recommends
that Travelers do their due diligence
it's wonderful that Adventure travel is
booming a B I think people really should
do their research and do their homework
and try and find the experiences that
are really good fits for them
despite the dangerous Elves and the
planet
the ultra wealthy tourists are
undeterred we keep wondering whether or
not things are going to start to subside
and the boom just continues so we're
seeing strong growth basically across
the entire sector